>> Kat: THEY LET THEIR HAIR GO
GRAY BUT IS THE STYLE HERE TO
STAY?
WOMEN'S LIB SAYS DITCH THE DIE,
WE'RE GOING GRAY THE TIME IS
NYE.
MANY WOMEN RETURNING TO THE
WORKPLACE ARE DECIDING TO
EMBRACE THEIR NATURAL GRAY HAIR
AS A SYMBOL OF EMPOWERMENT.
I PREFER COLLECTING SWORDS.
WITH HAIR SALONS CLOSED FOR
MONTHS DURING THE PANDEMIC,
WOMEN ACROSS THE COUNTRY LET THE
SILVER SHINE THROUGH.
PERFECT TIMING SINCE THEIR FACES
WERE ALREADY COVERED WITH
USELESS MASKS.
BOO.
AND NOW MANY FIND THAT KEEPING
IT NATURAL IS LIBERATING.
MEN PREFER THE TIME WOMEN
THOUGHT WEARING NO BRAH WAS
LIBERATING.
MANY WOMEN STILL FEEL JUDGED FOR
EXPOSING THEIR GRAY ROOTS OR
WILL BE PASSED UP FOR A
PROFESSIONAL OR ROMANTIC
OPPORTUNITIES.
ROMANTIC OPPORTUNITIES, I'M
GOING TO START CALLING IT THAT.
IF THEY DON'T DYE THEIR HEIR.
AND WHILE THEY GRAY AT THE SAME
RATE WHEN IT COMES TO HOW THE
SALT AND PEPPER ARE TREATED IT'S
BLACK AND WHITE.
HISTORICALLY GRAY MEN ARE
DESCRIBED AS WISE DISTINGUISHED
SILVER FOXES WHILE WOMEN WITH
GRAY HEIR ARE KNOWN AS NOT
BANGABLE ANYMORE.
BUT THE GRAY SCALE SEEMS TO BE
TIPPING AT LEAST MARGINALLY IN
WOMEN'S FAVOR.
YOUNGER GENERATIONS HAVE
PURPOSELY COLORED THEIR HEIR
GRAY AS A FAKES STATEMENT
PROVING IF YOU HAVE A YOUNG FACE
AND HOT BODY YOU CAN BE HOT NO
MATTER WHAT THE HAIR COLOR.
SO MAYBE THIS IS A PUSH TO
FINALLY GO GRAY IN THE
WORKPLACE.
WONDER HOW THAT WILL GO.
>> LOOKING GOOD GEORGE CLOONEY.
>> HEY, SILVER FOX.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> AH, LADY WITH GRAY HEIR?
>> OH MY GOSH.
>> SOMEBODY CALL 911 THIS WOMAN
MUST HAVE ESCAPED FROM A NURSING
HOME!
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Kat: EMILY IT'S TRUE AND IT'S
REAL AND IT'S NOT FAIR.
>> Emily: YES, AND MY TAKE AWAY
FROM THIS WHOLE THING WAS,
ESSENTIALLY WOMEN JUST HAVE TO
DO WHATEVER THEY WANT BECAUSE
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
PEOPLE THAT SAY YOUR GRAY HAIR
MAKES YOU NOT BANGABLE ANYMORE
AND OTHERS WILL SAY IT'S
BEAUTIFUL AND BE YOURSELF AND
THE KEY IS TO WEAR IT AND NOT
LET IT WEAR YOU.
WHATEVER MAKES YOU HAPPY AND
THRIVE DO IT.
I WILL SAY THE OTHER DAY I WAS
WALKING INTO A FOOTBALL GAME AND
THIS GIRLFRIEND IN HER SILVER
HAIR TREND DIED HER HAIR SILVER
AND FROM THE BACK I WAS LIKE WHY
IS RYAN LIKE WITH A GRANDMA AND
SHE TURNED HER FACE AND I WAS
LIKE, OH, THAT'S JEN.
SO I FEEL LIKE --
>> Kat:.
>> Kat: I HOPE JEN DOESN'T WATCH
THE SHOW.
>> Tyrus: LOOK AT HER ACTION.
>> Kat: THIS IS A WEIRD WAY TO
FIND OUT YOU'RE A SEXIST AGAINST
YOURSELF.
>> Emily: I'M JUST SAYING --.
>> Tyrus: YOU CAN'T CLEAN IT UP
YOU MISOGYNISTIC PIG.
I AM APPALLED.
>> Kat: APPALLED BY YOUR
INTERNALIZED MISOGYNY.
>> Tyrus: BOO THIS PERSON.
>> Emily: DON'T YOU DARE.
DON'T YOU DARE.
>> Kat: LARRY, YOU DON'T EVEN
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOUR
GRAY HEIR HAS NOT AFFECTED YOUR
STATUS AS A SEX SYMBOL.
>> Larry: I THINK EMILY NEEDS
DEFENSE AND SUPPORT.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU WERE
GOING WITH THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S SO GREAT
ABOUT GRAY HAIR, WHAT'S SO
UNGREAT ABOUT GRAY HAIR.
I'M STILL HUNG UP ON THE
BANGABLE PART.
AND I'M BASICALLY AFRAID TO
TOUCH THIS WHOLE THING SO I'M
GOING TO PASS THE BATON TO
SOMEBODY ELSE.
I'M STILL RECOVERING.
>> Tom: ACTUALLY I HAD THE SAME
EXPERIENCE AS EMILY BUT I DID
NOT HAVE THAT REACTION EMILY.
I LOOKED AT HER AND SAID, THAT
IS A HOT GRANDMA!
>> Tyrus: THAT'S A LITTLE BERMAN
MAN YES.
>> Kat: A LITTLE BETTER.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RULES ARE
SEXUALIZING GRANDMAS PROGRESS IN
THIS BUSINESS?
>> Emily: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
>> Kat: IS IT?
>> Tom: I THINK IT'S TRUE
BECAUSE WHEN I DO JOE BIDEN
EVERY DAY I LOOK AT MY HEIR IN
THE PHONE WHEN I'M DOING IT AND
I LOOK AT THE WAY I'M GOING TO
LOOK IN A FEW YEARS, I THINK IT
LOOKS PRETTY GOOD.
SO I THINK I'M GOING TO BE ONE
OF THOSE SILVER FOXES, RIGHT?
>> Larry: WE'RE ALMOST OUT OF
THIS SEGMENT RIGHT?
>> Kat: I THINK WE'RE DONE
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kat: I CAN TALK MORE ABOUT
BANGABLE BUT WE'VE GOT TO GO
UNFORTUNATELY.
>> Larry: THAT'S WHAT I WAS
AFRAID OF.
>> Kat: TYRUS?
>> Tyrus: I'M JUST DISGUSTED.
[LAUGHTER].
>> Tyrus: JUST WALK IN HERE AND
BESMIRCH WOMEN'S HAIR COLOR?
WOW, I'M GLAD YOU SAID THAT
BECAUSE I FEEL AS A MAN THERE'S
NO RIGHT OR WRONG ANSWER SO NO
MATTER WHAT I SAY WILL BE WRONG.
I'M COOL WITH GRAY MEANS I DON'T
CARE.
IF I SAY NO, I LIKE THE COLOR OF
YOUR HAIR, I'M AN ASS.
SO, YOU KNOW, JUST GO WITH WHAT
YOU KNOW, MAN.
YOU WANT TO BE GRAY, GO
WHATEVER.
JUST DON'T BORE ME.
>> Larry: THIS IS ONE OF THESE
LOSS/LOSS SEGMENTS THAT AS ALL
THERE IS TO IT.
>> Tyrus: IT'S A TRAP.
>> Larry: GOT TO BE DONE SOON.
>> Tyrus: NO MATTER WHAT, MY
ANSWER WASN'T AS HORRIBLE AS
THIS ONE.
>> Kat: THAT'S TRUE.
[LAUGHTER]
AND BY THE WAY JEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING I THINK YOU LOOK
AMAZING.
>> Tyrus: SHE DIDN'T SAY, SHE
WAS LIKE, YU, LOOK AT GRANDMA.
>> Kat: SHE WAS REVOLTED BY THE